the millions of unsolicited ballots  without any verification  measures well we're interrupting this  because  what the president of the united states  is saying in large part  is absolutely untrue  and we have to interrupt here because  the president has uh made a number of uh  false statements today morning he's been  making a lot of  frankly false accusations here we are  again  in the unusual position of not only  interrupting the president of the united  states but correcting the president of  the united states and ari melbourne  don't go far  [Music]  good evening i'd like to provide the  american people with an update on our  efforts  to protect the integrity of a very  important 2020 election  thank you very much thank you  you